si usted tiene cáncer su médico podría
recomendarle la quimioterapia como parte
de su tratamiento las células del cuerpo
crecen y se dividen como parte del ciclo
celular normal
el núcleo de la célula controla este
proceso
dentro de cada núcleo el material
genético llamado adn contiene las
instrucciones para dirigir este proceso
algunas veces el adn de la célula se
daña
generalmente el adn responde reparándose
a sí mismo o dándole instrucciones a la
célula para que muera
sin embargo en el cáncer se dañan
algunas partes del adn que dirige la
división celular
cuando se dañan estas secciones el adn
es incapaz de repararse por si mismo o
de provocar la muerte de la célula por
el contrario el adn dañado provoca que
la célula crezca y se divida de manera
incontrolada en más células dañadas
llamadas células cancerosas
a medida que las células se multiplican
y desplazan a las células normales se
forma un tumor
cuando el tumor aumenta de tamaño
desarrolla su propio suministro de
sangre
dado que las células cancerosas no se
mantienen unidas entre sí también como
las células normales pueden desprenderse
y entrar en un vaso sanguíneo cercano
las células cancerosas pueden viajar a
través de los vasos sanguíneos a otras
zonas del cuerpo y formar tumores
adicionales esto se llama metástasis
pueden formarse tumores adicionales en
zonas como los pulmones
el hígado
y los huesos
el cáncer también se puede diseminar a
otras zonas del cuerpo a través del
sistema linfático
y las células cancerosas pueden entrar a
los vasos linfáticos cercanos a los
tumores y viajar a pequeñas glándulas
llamadas nódulos linfáticos
si las células atraviesan los nódulos
pueden continuar viajando por el sistema
linfático y formar tumores adicionales
y los medicamentos para la quimioterapia
funcionan atacando a las células de
rápido crecimiento y reproducción
característica común de las células
cancerosas el tumor se reduce a medida
que las células dejan de dividirse y
mueren
y la mayoría de los medicamentos para la
quimioterapia trabajan de forma
sistémica mientras viajan por todo el
cuerpo a través del torrente sanguíneo
estos medicamentos mientras están
circulando dañan las células cancerosas
metastásicas presentes en otros órganos
desafortunadamente los medicamentos para
la quimioterapia no pueden diferenciar
entre las células normales de rápido
crecimiento y las células cancerosas
como resultado estos medicamentos
también dañan o irritan algunas células
normales de rápido crecimiento tales
como las de la médula ósea el sistema
digestivo y los folículos pilosos la
muerte irritación o daño de estas
células normales produce efectos
secundarios tales como un sistema inmune
débil náuseas y pérdida de cabello
el objetivo de la quimioterapia es
reducir o eliminar las células
cancerosas en el tumor original y en los
sitios de metástasis además de ser un
tratamiento primario para el cáncer con
frecuencia los médicos usan la
quimioterapia como un tratamiento
secundario antes durante o después de
otros tratamientos primarios para el
cáncer como la radioterapia o la
extirpación quirúrgica del tumor
dependiendo de la ubicación y el tipo de
cáncer usted puede recibir medicamentos
para quimioterapia destinados a circular
por su cuerpo incluyendo píldoras
cápsulas o líquidos por vía oral así
como inyecciones intravenosas o
intramuscular es de forma alternativa
usted puede recibir medicamentos
aplicados solo a la zona del tumor uno
de los métodos localizados consiste en
la aplicación de los medicamentos a su
vejiga o pecho a través de estrechos
tubos llamados catéteres otro método de
aplicación local es la inyección de los
medicamentos al fluido cerebroespinal
que rodea el cerebro y la médula espinal
un tercer método localizado consiste en
la colocación de láminas de lenta
disolución en la zona donde se extirpó
un tumor en la mayoría de los casos
usted recibirá diversos medicamentos de
quimioterapia para incrementar su
efectividad
podrá recibir muchos tratamientos de
quimioterapia distribuidos en un periodo
de semanas o meses esto le permite a su
organismo recuperarse entre los
tratamientos y matar el mayor número de
células cancerosas posible
y los efectos secundarios más comunes de
la quimioterapia incluyen la pérdida de
cabello náuseas disminución del apetito
fatiga anemia moretones y diarrea
es importante que descanse como
alimentos nutritivos y tome las
medicinas prescritas por su médico para
reducir o minimizar estos efectos
secundarios